Traduttore: Monica Parvanova
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Mio padre
era un agricoltore,
figlio di agricoltori,
di generazione in generazione.
Mia madre, figlia di allevatori
di vacche e pecore.
Da questi due genitori doveva
nascere un altro agricoltore
o, quanto meno, un allevatore.
Ma andando in campagna,
non mi piacevano gli odori,
non mi piacevano
le asprezze, le acidità,
che provenivano dai terreni concimati
con il nitrato di ammonio, il fosfato
e poi i campi di grano
diserbati con il glifosate
o altre molecole chimiche.
Quindi decisi di iscrivermi
a lingue e letterature straniere,
perché volevo andarmene via
dalla campagna e dalla Sicilia.
La malattia di mio padre
mi tenne però legato alla terra
e allora dovetti cercare di capire
perché avvertivo quegli odori
nauseabondi in campagna.
Cominciai a fare una ricerca
e vidi che la storia che stavo vivendo io
era la storia che aveva vissuto qualcuno
agli inizi del '900, una guerra mondiale,
e durante quella guerra mondiale
ci fu un uomo che risolvette
un problema alla Germania
per riuscire a fare gli esplosivi.
Fritz Haber riuscì a costruire un sistema
per sintetizzare il nitrato di ammonio,
che serve per fare gli esplosivi.
Il nitrato di ammonio
viene utilizzato oggi
in tutte le aziende agricole,
per dare energia alle piante.
Ma sempre il solito amico Fritz
riuscì anche a inventare una formula
del gas mostarda, chiamato iprite,
perché venne utilizzato per la prima volta
durante la prima guerra mondiale
per testarlo ad Ypres, in Belgio.
In una notte ci furono 100.000 morti.
Questa iprite venne poi evoluta,
perché si dovevano gasare,
uccidere, sterminare,
circa 6 milioni di persone,
nei campi di sterminio.
E allora venne fatto lo Zyklon A
che venne evoluto in Zyklon B,
sempre utilizzando la formula
dell'iprite come base.
Riuscirono a eliminare una buona
parte della nostra umanità
che vive sul pianeta.
Ma questo Zyklon B servì anche da base
per riuscire a formulare l'agente arancio,
che venne utilizzato in Vietnam
per defoliare le foreste,
che servivano a far nascondere
i Vietcong che difendevano le loro risaie.
Si chiama agente arancio, perché
dopo esser passato sulle foglie
le foglie diventano rosse,
arancioni e cadono.
Quindi queste sono le raccomandazioni
per fare agricoltura oggi.
Visto questo, era logico per me scappare
da un posto altamente inquinato.
Però un giorno mi ritrovai come davanti
a una porta, che però era murata.
Dietro sapevo che c'era la storia
di un antico magazzino di frumento.
Era scolpito anche nella pietra chiave
di questo magazzino: una spiga.
Ho detto: "C'è qualcosa che devo
riuscire a farmi dare dal passato".
Allora andai in un vecchio
villaggio medievale,
dove ancora ci sono gli abitanti,
a Montalbano Elicona,
dove un'anziana signora ci racconta
che lì vicino al bosco di Malabotta
c'è un posto chiamato Argimusco,
dove c'erano i giganti e gli dei.
Non potete comprendere
la gioia dei miei bambini,
quando sentirono dire che là
vicino c'erano stati i giganti.
E allora andammo lì,
a cercare le opere dei giganti,
e su un'altura chiamata
Argimusco, dove c'è l'Orante...
È il profilo di una donna
che sta pregando,
dove vengono anche
dall'India per meditare.
Ci sono delle figure di profili
dove Esiodo dice che i titani Cronos
e Rea generano Istie e Demetra.
Demetra è la dea del grano,
la dea dell'agricoltura.
Allora capii che c'era qualcosa di strano.
Vedemmo che in quel posto vissero
degli esseri particolari: i terrestri.
Però per riuscire ad attingere
alla storia e anche al pensiero,
a trovare un collegamento
tra quello che fecero loro,
mi servivano dei codici, delle chiavi,
per aprire quella porta murata.
E allora trovai qui i codici,
alla Stazione Sperimentale
di Granicoltura di Caltagirone,
ente storico del 1927,
dove ci sono tutti i 50 frumenti locali,
antichi e siciliani, 45 duri e 5 teneri,
che erano lì pronti
e aspettavano qualcuno
che li cominciasse
a riprodurre, a moltiplicare
e a spargere sulla terra, sul territorio
della nostra bellissima isola.
E allora iniziammo da pochi grammi
e cominciammo a seminarli,
a fare delle parcelle,
questo lavoro che fa già la stazione,
ma noi cominciammo
a seminarne sempre di più.
Questa è la zona da dove poi
questi semi vengono prelevati e sparsi.
Nell'arco di tre anni da pochi ettari
siamo arrivati a 700 ettari in Sicilia
e produciamo migliaia di tonnellate
di frumento, mai mutato geneticamente,
che ha un glutine assolutamente diverso,
quello che ci avevano tolto dalla tavola,
propinandoci un altro glutine.
Allora bisognava cercare i codici.
Il frumento è un codice
che ha attivato la nostra civiltà,
e quindi era giusto recuperarlo,
per riuscire a digitare il giusto codice,
affinché non ci venga ritirato più
il bancomat o la nostra carta di credito.
Ma dobbiamo farci dare l'energia
giusta, digitando il codice giusto.
E questi grani, quindi...
Da qui si parte con un'opera
di comunicare ai bambini,
per evitare che si perda la memoria,
perché è nel momento in cui noi
perdiamo la memoria e la conoscenza
che perdiamo la nostra
occasione di evoluzione.
E per recuperare la memoria
bisogna rifare, ripristinare
le azioni, fatte tanti e tanti anni fa.
Ma non per un ritorno al passato,
ma è per fare un memoriale,
dove riuscire a far rivivere delle azioni
che provocano un'altra energia,
smuovono altre onde, senti altri rumori.
Vedere paesaggi di grani antichi,
collegati lì in fondo
al castello di Pietratagliata.
E far sì che... si accoppiano bene,
il grano antico con un castello
medievale, si accoppia bene.
E quindi riuscire anche
a riottenere un paesaggio diverso.
Mario produce cibo,
Giuseppe ha la conoscenza.
Queste sono persone che stanno
ai margini e però hanno loro le soluzioni.
E poi incontrando Ceccarelli,
uno scienziato italiano che vive in India,
la diversità,
dove noi non cerchiamo più
l'uniformità, lo standard, l'omogeneità
all'interno di un campo di grano,
ma abbiamo delle miscele
di tantissime varietà,
per attivare la variabilità, la diversità,
all'interno di un campo di grano,
dove una spiga non è uguale all'altra,
ma sono tutte spighe
una diversa dall'altra.
La più bassa sostiene
la più alta, in caso di vento.
La più alta difende la più bassa,
in caso di infestanti.
Ecco la diversità, che non è un errore,
come nei campi di grano moderno,
non è terrore, non è orrore la diversità,
ma la diversità è ricchezza,
è occasione di cambiamento,
ma è l'unica occasione
per poterti agganciare alle evoluzioni,
come in questo periodo,
i cambiamenti climatici.
Il clima sta cambiando,
i tempi stanno cambiando.
Dobbiamo essere capaci di evolverci,
ma più elementi diversi abbiamo dentro
di noi, accanto a noi, attorno a noi,
più occasioni noi abbiamo
di poter evitare di morire.
E quindi in natura non è
l'essere più forte che vince,
ma è l'essere che ha
più capacità di adattamento.
Poi anche la FAO ha detto:
"Sai, sei un caso studio."
Come? Dovete studiare
me? Che significa?
"No, no, stai facendo delle cose buone.
Va bene, non sei un caso particolare."
Divulgo questo anche ad altri
contadini, altri agricoltori in Sicilia,
perché è giusto essere anche in tanti,
ma cerchiamo la collaborazione anche
all'esterno, non solamente nella campagna.
La vogliamo nella città, nelle strade,
nei negozi, nelle vostre menti,
affinché nelle vostre menti
si formi un concetto di qualità del cibo,
che è il vostro cibo, la vostra energia,
per riuscire a sostenere
la vostra vita, la vostra famiglia
e quella della società, in cui
noi viviamo tutti quanti.
Un bambino sta cercando
di spostare un ballone di 350 kg,
ci è riuscito per pochi centimetri.
Faccio un appello a tutti quanti:
venite, dateci una mano d'aiuto,
perché nei campi di grano
della nostra società
bisogna togliere un sacco di balle,
che sono state disseminate
in questi ultimi 60 anni.
(Applausi)